I need you to listen very very carefully
to what I'm about to tell you the
President of the United States the the
United States that's currently
investigating Russia for election
hacking and meddling and interference
Donald Trump is open to having Russian
investigators come here to the United
States and question American citizens
okay it's very important that I have
complete and total clarity on this the
United States is investigating Trump and
Russia for election obstruction and
hacking and interference and
manipulation
we've already indicted 25 Russians Putin
is doing nothing about it just letting
them sit in Russia which is of course
something he's allowed to do there's no
extradition deal it's fine but what
Donald Trump is conceivably willing to
do is to let Russians come here to the
United States and interview American
citizens who haven't been indicted of
anything including specifically former
United States Ambassador Michael McFaul
here it is straight from the horse's
mouth
Trump press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders thank you Sarah Russian
authorities yesterday named several
Americans who they want to question that
they claimed were involved in Hill
brothers quote-unquote crimes and
terms including a former ambassador to
russia michael mcfaul this president
Trump's support that idea is he open to
having US officials questions versus the
president's gonna meet with his team and
we'll let you know when we have an
announcement on that for a second is
that a topic that came up in their
conversation was including raisin Smith
president Ron there was some
conversation about it but there wasn't a
commitment made on behalf of the United
States and the president will work with
his team and we'll let you know if
there's an announcement on that front
like no commitment was made no
commitment was made the right answer
would be no we're not letting Russian
investigators question American citizens
on American soil they have no
jurisdiction they have no charges and
the answer is simply no but instead it's
it was mentioned and no commitment has
been made as of this point Russia
reportedly also wants the question
Christopher Steele who of course is
British he's the author of the now
infamous Trump Russia dossier and Russia
would love American help in making that
happen as well nothing suspicious right
just that Russia wants to question the
guy who did the research and came up
with historic dirt on the President of
the United States of America then
candidate for the presidency of the
United States of America and former
ambassador Michael McFaul actually
tweeted about this saying hey White
House press corps can you confirm
tomorrow with White House press
secretary sarah huckabee sanders that
putin discussed me personally in his
one-on-one with donald trump did he
suggest that i was part of some alleged
money laundering scheme and did trump
push back on this completely invented
wacko idea we've been throwing around
the word treason with regard to actions
where you'd really need to know a little
more about the intent and the specifics
of the law to say definitively whether
it is isn't or might be treasonous the
mere idea that an american president
would consider turning over a former
ambassador to a foreign power for
investigation of his actions but not
just actions that he undertook as a
private citizen specifically the actions
that
former ambassador McFaul undertook as
ambassador of the United States to
Russia as part of his Federal service is
absolutely and completely outrageous and
there are some Republicans and most
Democrats who are completely outraged by
this although of course at this point it
seems that some Republicans will go
along with absolutely anything that's
proposed what on earth must Putin have
on Trump for this to even receive a
glimmer of consideration there's the
glimmer of consideration and this all
connects to a guy named Bill Browder
bill Browder is a guy that Putin has
been after for a long time and the
targeting of former ambassador McFaul is
more than likely related to that since
Putin says McFaul was in cahoots with
Browder this is every indication is that
this is a targeted personal vendetta by
Vladimir Putin and by the President of
the United States against Michael McFaul
and specifically against Bill Browder
and shockingly the President of the
United States seems to be not only
complicit but actually eager to
participate in this thing but Vladimir
Putin has Donald Trump bending over
backwards for him and you had better get
registered to vote that's my sort of
wrap it all up thought on this if you're
not registered to vote and you're not
planning to vote on November 6th of this
year then you must not be paying
attention or you simply don't care
because that is the level of absolute
and total depravity that we're
experiencing here and a lot of this is
part of a broader narrative that has
been crafted and that's what I want to
talk to you about next today's episode
is made possible in part by better help
calm slash Pakman I've spoken about the
unfair and unfortunate stigma that there
can be around therapy there shouldn't be
and better help makes things even easier
for you if you've been thinking about
getting involved and working with a
therapist you get access to fully
licensed experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer all you have to do is go to
better help calm slash Pakman you fill
out a questionnaire they match you with
a counselor that'll work best for you
you
ask if you want that your therapist not
be religious if that is important to you
and at any point if you think your
therapist is not a good fit
you can switch and work with somebody
else it's less expensive than seeing a
counselor in person but better help also
gives you unlimited access to your
counselor you can talk to them every day
if you want you will not get that with
an in-person therapist so go to better
help calm slash Pakman so easy to sign
up and get started we've put a link in
the video description if you're watching
on YouTube check it out better help calm
slash PA que ma N